gestern war so moment ist normalerweise
hätte ich nach dem spiel auch gestern
abend eine kleine ansprache an die
spieler gehalten aber absolut nicht
möglich sobald ich bestimmte dinge
angesprochen haben selbst wenn ich
darüber nachgedacht habe habe ich
angefangen zu lernen so ist nicht so
cool aber war halt so
mittlerweile gehen aber das ist kein
neuer ist seit der an mir das mal keine
seite die häufig zum vorschein kommen zu
lassen also 10 15 sekunden vorm
schlusspfiff dann auch ich gedacht sie
die wird es nicht mehr gewinnen und habe
da meine familie angerufen habe allen
gesagt wie sehr ich sie liebe habe dann
gesagt zu haben und bleiben dann
telefonisch externe von ist auf den
tisch dann sei der praktisch dabei und
so war es dann auch und dann haben wir
uns alle sehr gefreut es war hoch
emotional weil es einfach so wahnsinnig
groß ist was da passiert es ist für uns
nicht normales wert für niemand normal
ist aber in diesem speziellen fall an in
diesem klub ganz besonders
außerordentlich und groß und das ist mir
gestern aufgefallen ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass sich zu große anfühlt wenn
es wenn es eintritt aber es ist wir
haben soll ich habe es noch keine 30
jahre gewartet aber alle hatten dann
mehr oder weniger und das haben wir
schon auch gespürt und so die last von
ihm abgefallen ist plus die freude
darüber dass es geklappt hat
das war ein extremer mix und nicht alle
bereiche meines körpers waren aufsicht
ich bereit oder dafür bereit das damit
richtig umzugehen